Jacob is with us in Sacramento hi Jacob
how are you just the same sir how can I
help so I've got a question about when
you sell a car so I Drive a 2005 Honda
it's got like a hundred and eighty-one
thousand miles on it and I'm planning to
drive it into the ground but I guess my
question is when do you know it's
financially a good idea to get out of
that vehicle and not continue putting
repairs into it
you know the weird thing is that you can
hardly ever justify selling a car based
on repairs financially let me give you
an example okay if you say okay the car
drive the car all the way down to it's a
two thousand dollar car it's not yet but
someday okay you know three hundred
thousand miles on it you've worn the
wheels off of it and and you have a five
hundred dollar or even a thousand dollar
repair right yeah and you say well you
know these repairs are killing me I'm
gonna go buy a nice another little Honda
for twelve thousand bucks well the first
year that car is going to go down more
than the cost of that repair on the old
one so almost never can you justify
mathematically buying a better car based
on the math those are based on the gas
mileage even very few people drive long
enough miles to justify the difference
on gas mileage especially cheapest gas
is now so the whole Prius thing is a
freaking joke you know in terms of
figuring out a way to buy a thirty
thousand dollar car versus a twenty
thousand dollar car and make up that ten
thousand dollars for the gas mileage
you'd have to drive the freaking thing
to the moon mathematically okay so you
can't do it based on the math so what it
comes down to is if you're going to buy
a Prius you're doing that because you're
worried about the planet or whatever
you're doing I mean on the you know the
the environmental issues right now in
your case what we're saying is it comes
down to hassle factor and the purchase
of the newer vehicle is a small enough
percentage of your world
that the hassle factor is worth more
than whatever that is you know and so
let's say you're making you know you're
making a hundred and a half and you go
buy a $20,000 car you pay cash for it
and you move up out of this car that
you've driven down to 3,000 bucks in
value and you really don't get anything
except reliability for that and a
lowered repair bill but I mean the
difference in 17,000 bucks you'll never
get that back in repairs okay you know
what I'm saying it's just you got a
little nicer car it's a creature comfort
and you don't have you know you're not
sitting on the side of the interstate
with your cell phone in your hand trying
to figure out how to get off the you
know off the side of the shoulder here
so because it's a pain in the butt to
breakdown right so at some point it's
just hassle factor and comfort as a
percentage of your net worth and your
income it's a non-issue so you move up
in car and that's a reasonable thing but
you really can't mathematically justify
the expense but you'd never repair it
you mean you could rebuild the whole
freakin little car you know and and
still would be less in it then then you
paid to move up okay that make sense so
I but it's still I still would tell you
to move up at some point and not and not
bark at you about it and you know my
rule on cars is all of your things with
motors in them added together should be
less than half your annual income and
you pay cash for them okay yeah I can do
that the plan is eventually when when
the element dies to go and get a Subaru
Impreza that's used and you know yeah in
our cash flow scenario yeah and you pay
cash for it and you but again you're
moving from the element which might be
worth three or four thousand bucks at
the time and you move up from that into
maybe a fifteen thousand dollar Subaru
right yeah yeah that that's what three
years old or something at that time and
low miles or something in there and and
yeah do that and we tell people not to
buy a brand new car for these exact same
reasons unless you have a net worth of
at least a million dollars now once
you've got a million dollar net worth
the loss in value on a brand new car is
a small enough percentage of your world
it's not ruining your life
but when you got no money and you make
50 grand and you're driving a thirty
thousand dollar car that's stupid zone
yeah you're not there but I mean for our
listeners sake you know that we tell
people that because you you're just
losing your butt every day do every time
you start the car you lost another
thousand bucks you know it's just crazy
and then you scratch your head and
wonder why your kids college fund isn't
funded and that's what we tell people
not to do so you're on track here but I
also want to give people permission to
you know drive it down till the wheels
fall off that's fine but go ahead and
move up when you've got the cash and
when you got yourself in good financial
condition you're out of debt you got the
emergency fund in place you got a car
you got some car money above that and
then get you a decent vehicle I don't
mind you doing that at all I was trying
to encourage a young friend of mine
who's got a net worth of about a million
dollars this weekend go ahead and you
know she was not wanting to buy a new
car and I said you know you're in good
shape
you're just being a tightwad you know go
get the the difference in the new one
and the other one I would get a new one
and I bought new cars but only in the
last few years as I've gotten my net
worth up there okay hey man thanks for
the call
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
you
[Music]